and one team that is not seriously in
the mix but technically still in the
hunt for a playoff berth the Carolina
Panthers and NBS while you were just
speaking I looked at the group text
message that we all share where we call
flyballs as to who's going to write what
story
Josh Alper just notified is that the
Carolina Panthers have fired Ron Rivera
so we get a chance to react to that with
absolutely no opportunity to think about
it reflect on it first thing that comes
to mind when you see that Ron Rivera is
out in Carolina well the first thing
that comes to my mind is it wasn't very
long ago that he was coaching the
Panthers in the Super Bowl and it just
shows you how quickly things can shift
in the NFL that he had this team in the
Super Bowl Cam Newton was the league MVP
that year and he was a still a young
quarterback who we thought had many good
years ahead of them it has really gone
downhill in a hurry
I think Cam Newton's health has been the
biggest reason for that but I think
there's always more than one reason when
you look at a team declining the way the
Panthers have and the other thing that I
think for Ron Rivera is there's a
different owner now there's not an owner
who has any reason to be loyal to him
there's not the owner who hired him is
long gone and when a new owner comes in
you never know how secure your job is
and for Ron Rivera it turned out it was
not all that secure yeah and the team
has made the announcement that Rivera is
out and this wasn't leaked this wasn't
reported nobody as far as I can tell got
the 5-minute heads-up
but Norv Turner is out and Perry fee
well remember him being a hothead
coaching candidate and I think that he
was an interim coach somewhere at some
point in the past ten years he's been
named the interim head coach Norv Turner
will transition to special assistant to
the head coach his son Scott takes over
as offensive coordinator so no
is kind of out too right no I mean why
not let north be the offensive
coordinator but now his son Scott
becomes that coordinator and Perry fuel
takes over as the interim head coach and
and here's my thought on it because I've
actually been meaning to go back to the
final episode of the all-or-nothing
series that premiered over the summer
featuring the Carolina Panthers from
2018 because what resonated with me was
the final episode new owner David Tepper
was explaining while he was riding in a
vehicle as they were talking about plans
for 2019 and a practice facility who
wants to have built and he's playing
South Carolina off against North
Carolina to get the best possible deal
he said that the NFL is set up for all
teams to be a 10-8 and where you go from
there
up or down depends upon key factors like
quarterback coach and GM and nobody buys
a team because they want to employ the
coach who's in place
nobody says gee I can pick ten different
teams
I want Ron Rivera's team David Tepper
bought the team that was available
so David tempers gonna have his own
ideas as to who he wants to coach the
team and last year
Tepper did not make any changes he was
still getting his feet wet now he's had
more of an opportunity to understand
what it takes to run an NFL team more of
an opportunity to think about who he
would want to be his coach and now he's
able to implement his path going forward
and I think Marty her knee needs to be
concerned about this as well I think we
could see temperament run at Kevin
Kolbert the Steelers GM who is on a
year-to-year arrangement and even though
it's been a long time since Bill Cowher
last coached I think that's a name to
keep in mind all because of those
Pittsburgh connections for David Tepper
connections to the Steelers connections
to Pittsburgh and I it look all bets are
off at this point as to who he hires but
it doesn't surprise me that this
happened it surprised me that it's
happening now and it's funny I was just
and I said this tongue-in-cheek
to my son yesterday when I was looking
at the traffic for the day on a Monday I
said and it was a joke but it's kind of
funny I said man we need to get a coach
fired to get a nice little bump in
traffic because usually there's somebody
else who's let go
and here's Ron Rivera second straight
year the Panthers collapsing in the
second half and David Tepper exercising
that prerogative to put everyone on
notice now that he's going to be looking
for a coach and to begin the process of
luhrmann director as he's he's very rich
he's all I know fellow owners are
obviously wealthy but he is wealthier
than I think the last estimate I saw he
was the wealthiest NFL owner so he can
certainly afford to pay more if if
there's a bidding war for a head coach
who has multiple teams who want him and
David Tepper really wants him I don't
think anyone's gonna outbid the Panthers
if it comes down to money and I think he
will be aggressive about not just
settling for yeah this guy was a pretty
good coordinator in a couple other
places let's hire him I I suspect David
Tepper will want to make a splash will
want to hire the kind of name coach that
gets people talking that gets people
saying WOW the Panthers they're they're
really trying something interesting and
then of course the next question will be
whoever that name coaches does he'll of
Cam Newton does he say hey I'm gonna
build my offense around what Cam Newton
does get Cam Newton healthy again and
start taking advantage of Cam Newton's
unique athletic talents or does he hire
a coach who says I want to bring in my
own quarterback to run my own system
Cam Newton isn't a good fit for my
system I'm getting my guy and Cam Newton
isn't gonna be here anymore so a lot of
really interesting questions to see and
it could go either way you know we I
don't
even have a strong opinion about what it
means for Cam Newton's future right now
but you could easily see one coach who
might have an offensive system in mind
where the presence of Cam Newton is an
attractive part of the job to him or
another coach who might say I'm bringing
in my own quarterback from my own system
let's get Cam Newton out of here and get
whatever we can for him in a trade
that's why I think it's important for
David Tepper to seriously consider
hiring a new GM as well so the GM and
the coach are on the same page about the
future of Cam Newton and when Cam
Newton's future came up several weeks
ago I said you can't make a decision on
Cam Newton until you make a decision
about who's gonna be making the decision
on Cam Newton and I don't like the idea
of tying a coach's hands with Cam Newton
III don't like the idea of interviewing
candidates with this prerequisite that
you must be on board with Cam Newton
because you can have a guy who says yeah
I'm on board with Cam Newton then once
he gets a five-year fully guaranteed
contract he's not gonna be on board with
Cam Newton I think it's time for
band-aids to get ripped off the Carolina
Panthers the current system isn't
working and the idea that that there's
almost a fatigue and I feel like Colts
fans were going through this with Andrew
Luck Panthers fans go through it with
became Newton the idea that there's
always something to worry about
physically with Cam Newton you want a
quarterback that doesn't constantly have
you biting your fingernails waiting for
the next injury and worrying that the
guy is gonna be healthy and it's always
something he's rehabbing from now Cam
Newton never actually missed a lot of
time but he was always hampered by
something last year it was the shoulder
this year it's the foot what's it gonna
be next year how do we strike the
balance between Cam Newton being as
physical as he can be with that six foot
five frame and he looks like he he is
truly a superhero and and a man among
boys how do you rein in the temptation
to use him that way and and what and
it's just yeah why do you want to worry
about that let's start over again let's
rip the band-aid off and let's go ahead
and and get a new quarterback but I
think the new coach and if there's a new
GM the new GM need to be given the
opportunity to make their decisions and
also to keep the cards close to
vest so if you do decide to trade a Cam
Newton whoever you're trading him to
believes that there's a chance you may
keep him so you can get the best
possible deal so that's the big surprise
on Tuesday afternoon as we begin the pft
p.m. podcast next question let's
continue this let's let's continue to
react to this with absolutely no time to
think about it in advance what happens
with Ron Rivera there are some coaches
where if a guy gets fired he's instantly
in demand is Ron Rivera a guy who is
going to emerge on a shortlist somewhere
else and get hired next year like Adam
GaSe did and Mike McCarthy didn't I am
going to guess no and I'm gonna guess
that he is an assistant head coach or
defensive coordinator in 2020 but the
resume is pretty good you know like like
we said he has taken the Panthers to the
Superbowl
he has been I would say overall an
above-average head coach during his
tenure with the Panthers and we could
easily see a set of circumstances namely
Cam Newton being healthy in which Ron
Rivera would not be fired today so with
with all those things said it certainly
wouldn't be a bad hire for some team to
hire him in 2020 but my guess is he's
not going to be the direction that any
team wants to go in and Ron Rivera is
not just a coach of the year he's a
two-time coach of the year it went Bruce
Arians Ron Rivera Bruce Arians Ron
Rivera 2012 through 2015 Rivera won at
2013 Rivera won at 2015 and I remember
back when he was the defensive
coordinator of the Chargers every time
they played Peyton Manning
they gave him fits and I advocated for
years anybody in the AFC South that is
looking for a coach why the hell are you
not hiring Ron Rivera he knows how to
defend against Peyton Manning so you
know Rivera's a guy who has proven his
worth he's proven he can coach he's gone
to a Super Bowl he's been coached here
twice and look
but we can go through a bunch of the
teams and we eventually will go through
the teams once we have a chance to
really digest this that could want a Ron
Rivera but I think anybody that is
currently thinking about a new coach for
2020 needs to factor in Ron Rivera
whether it's the Giants whether it's the
Browns whether and look I mean look at
the work he's done with Cam Newton first
overall pick in the draft Heisman Trophy
winner right he knows how to handle a
franchise quarterback even though he's a
defensive guy and here's another thing
to keep in mind what if you're a team
that is interested in Cam Newton does it
help to have Ron Rivera as your head
coach he's the only head coach that Cam
Newton's ever known MDS
yeah and that that would be a
fascinating thing to watch is this some
other team ends up both hiring Ron
Rivera and training for Cam Newton and
that that could absolutely happen and it
wouldn't necessarily be you know so
often we think of a quarterback in a
coach linked because the coach runs an
offensive system Ron Rivera of course is
a defensive minded head coach but it
could make a lot of sense for Ron Rivera
and Cam Newton to to sort of be a
package deal and you know there's been a
couple of times that they butted heads I
mean probably the one that got the most
attention was when Ron Rivera wouldn't
let Cam Newton start a game because he
violated the team dress code by not
wearing a tie on the team bus he had one
series where Derek Anderson actually
started the game because Ron Rivera was
sending a message to Cam Newton but it
has never felt like the two of them
can't work together hate each other or
anything like that it has more felt like
Ron Rivera wants to challenge Cam Newton
to do everything the right way
as a franchise quarterback and I think
Cam Newton actually appreciates that
about Ron Rivera so I don't think these
two guys necessarily need a split I
could see these two guys working
together at some other job down the road
it's it's a fascinating
concept and you know I've made the
argument and I don't want to advocate
for Anthony Lynn to be fired by the
charges because I think he's done a good
job there and I don't know that Ron
Rivera's the answer this question but my
arguments been the Chargers need to be
making all of their decisions
recognizing the reality that they are in
Los Angeles and there needs to be some
sizzle along with the substance of all
decisions and I've argued for Cam Newton
to be the next coach or the next
quarterback excuse me now that would be
sizzle if he's the next coach of the
Chargers but to be the next quarterback
of the Chargers and it would be
interesting to see if the Chargers would
want to bring Ron Rivera back in the
capacity as head coach they know him
from his days as a coordinator so a lot
of fascinating ways that this can unfold
but just as it gives the Panthers an
extra four weeks to get a head start on
their next move it gives Ron Rivera an
extra four weeks to get a head start on
his next move so we'll be covering that
story from every angle at Pro Football
Talk comm and now we have concluded the
introductory phase of this pft p.m.
podcast
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports